these were police officers does that
have any impact does that change
anything well I'd like to introduce you
to a woman named Kathy hokel who is the
governor of uh New York and uh she has
sort of expanded this throughout New
York City it's happening everywhere so
check this out this is wild this is CNN
they're analyzing what's going on with
these migrants and why they do this in
New York and why it only happens in
these blue cities and states check this
out in the back you don't you don't
touch our police officers touch anybody
thank you everybody I mean we're hearing
a change when it comes to immigration in
general from President Biden on down do
you hear her talk about that it is also
directly related to the fact that these
were police officers does that have any
impact does that change anything well
it's so complicated because you know
you're a New Yorker you move through the
city every day as I do we see these
people we touch these people they're out
looking for work they're delivering our
food they're at the gas stations and the
car wash um I mean these these are
people who came in waves you know
170,000 probably to New York City um but
within that group this hardworking you
know throngs of people in search of Hope
and a better life there is this 1center
you know criminal element that looks at
a different opportunity here these
individuals I went over their wrap
sheets yesterday multiple charges Grand
Larsen robbery attempted robbery grand
larsy grand larsy uh this particular
crew operated on mopeds and scooters
they were doing organized retail theft
they were doing snatches on the street
iPhones iPads clothing so on and so
forth um one of them that they are still
seeking has 10 charges on one day
because he's part of a pattern that's
been going on and I'm looking at the
dates that their arrest started which is
probably close to when they got here
they've only been here a couple of
months so what the detectives are
telling me is they have Crews here that
operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
well why don't they just stay in steel
in Florida and they said cuz there you
go to jail
oh great rep keep us
ni Fair Point oh but what jail laws I
can't believe it Florida and then they
go back to New York to steal again so I
guess as a Floridian I should thank
these people keep doing it hoko go for
it Adams open up all of your stores let
them steal all your stuff allow them to
come down here Aron well I don't want
them down here but you could see the you
can see the logic in it spend all your
cash down here try to steal some pants
at Lululemon and get your brains blown
out that would be just fine but we'd
rather you just go back and keep doing
it